[Music]
whether the assurance of acting from a
conviction of duty
is true whether what is done is actually
a duty these questions or doubts have no
meaning
when addressed to conscience to ask
whether the assurance is true would
presuppose that the inner intention is
different from the one put forward
that is that what the individual self
wills can be separated from duty
from the will of the universal and pure
consciousness the latter would be put
into words but the former would
be strictly the true motive of the
action
but this distinction between the
universal consciousness
and the individual self is just what has
been superseded and the supersession of
it
is conscience the self's immediate
knowing that it is certain of itself is
law and duty
its intention through being its own
intention
is what is right all that is required
is that it should know this and should
state its conviction
that it's knowing and willing or right
the declaration
of this assurance in itself rids the
form of its particularity it thereby
acknowledges the necessary universality
of the self
in calling itself conscience it calls
itself
pure knowledge of itself and pure
abstract willing
that is it calls itself a universal
knowing and willing which recognizes and
acknowledges
others is the same
for them for they are just this pure
self-knowing and willing
and which for that reason is also
recognized and acknowledged by them
in the will of the self that is certain
of itself in this
knowledge that the self is essential
being lies the essence
of what is right therefore whoever says
he acts in such and such a way from
conscience speaks the truth
for his conscience is the self that
knows and wills
but it is essential that he should
should say so
for this self must be at the same time
the universal self
it is not universal in the content of
the act for this
on account of its specificity is
intrinsically an indifferent affair
it is in the form of the act that the
universality lies
it is this form which is to be
established as actual
it is the self which as such is actual
in
language which declares itself to be the
truth
and just by so doing acknowledges all
other selves
and is acknowledged by them
in paragraph 654 we see hegel
continuing to develop for us
what conscience is and how it works and
we've brought
in language in in some of the earlier
paragraphs it's always been there since
it's the medium by which we've been
carrying out
all of this along with thought and and
you know action in the world and all
these other things
language is going to be only discussed
at certain points within
hegel's phenomenology but it's but it's
really inescapable and so when it comes
to the four
we really do want to pay attention to it
and in this paragraph not explicitly but
implicitly we see something
going on within hegel that's going to
prefigure
some of the great insights about
language
in 20th century thinkers
but framed in in hegel's own terminology
and in light of what what he's
particularly interested in
so what's happening here we're
setting up conscience which
is now claiming to be
universal knowing and willing
you know this this entire morality
section
we began from the individual after
freedom and the terror
uh being this this person in whom
um you know the the totality of every
value could could reside
that's a big claim that can't really
rest on
anybody's shoulders once it starts
weighing on them
and what we're going to see here in this
section when we
read it carefully is that all the things
that
from this point of view in the
phenomenology and it's not the point of
view
of spirit you know itself or of hegel
but rather of conscience as a particular
mode of self-consciousness right so
consciousness in relation to others what
we're seeing
is that its viewpoint on itself is
ultimately going to be
unsustainable to go back to an earlier
section
conscience itself is engaging
in you know dissimulation
or deception but deception of itself and
deception of
of others so what is going on let's take
a look at the text itself he says
whether the assurance of acting
from a conviction an uber zoigun right
being convinced of duty is true
or whether what is done is actually a
duty
these questions or doubts
have no meaning when addressed to
conscience
now have no meaning
well when when we say that something
is nonsense or meaningless or has no
significance
sometimes what we mean by that is that
it's literally
you know undecipherable if i just say
and we'll use an interesting example
here blah blah blah blah blah
right and we think about that
linguistically what is that
that is an expression that we use to
mean
meaningless unimportant superficial
repetitive diction writing whatever
somebody is doing so
uh that's more blah blah blah right
we're dismissing it
but now notice if you were to go
somewhere else
and you're talking with non-english
speakers and you were to say well that's
you know in their language you know blah
blah blah
they might look at you strangely and
wonder what's this repetition that's
going on
does this mean something is this
significative what is a blah
what would be the importance of saying
it three times in a row it is
culturally conditioned right even
nonsense
what counts as nonsense what gets
signified as nonsense
is not quite so simple as pure
meaninglessness
or valuelessness so
to say that this is without any
significance or meaningless
for for duty these questions are
not for duty but rather for conscience
as a shape of consciousness
yes it's that conscience doesn't want to
deal with these things
and dismisses them but they actually are
quite important these are the things
that have preoccupied
us throughout trying to figure out what
duties actually are and what action in
accordance with duty is
so they're not totally unimportant
he says these questions or doubts
doubting you know is is what i'm doing
actually the right thing is it my
moral duty my obligation or am i
indulging myself in you know satisfying
my
own desires and inclinations and calling
it duty
you know as kant pointed out to us very
often action in accordance with duty has
a secret spring of self-love concealed
within it right
so am i actually following my duty
is my conviction my being convinced
my being convicted the way that that uh
protestant christians
these days use that term of duty
true or am i
let's take a few examples am i acting
out of uh some sort of internalized
guilt that came to me from my parents or
for a cult from culture or something
like that
i mean this is you know freud's notion
of the super and i don't think you have
to like take on all of freud
in order to see that that conception has
actually got something behind it people
do
internalize not just the moral norms of
their culture or society or family or
whatever it happens to be
they also sort of internalize that voice
of those people saying you should do
this
you're a bad boy you know you you must
not do this
dirty child all those sorts of things
maybe my conviction of duty is coming
from that or maybe my conviction of duty
is coming from the wish to be viewed as
a good person when i'm really not a good
person
or we could come up with all sorts of
other examples
as well maybe i'm you know a new person
in the era that we inhabit where people
come up with new platforms
that are going to revolutionize
education revolutionize the workflows
i'm talking about online platforms right
revolutionize this we're going to change
it the whole world is going to be
different
and it's going to be better i could say
well that's my that's my duty
to bring forth this software platform
that makes everything better
but i might just be telling myself a
whole bunch of lies
about whether it's my duty or not and
whether you know the thing that i'm
bringing forth is actually good and
whether it represents what's best in
humanity
so this question of truth is is an
important one
conscience here's the real important
part of this conscience
doesn't want to consider those things
he says to ask whether the assurance is
true
would presuppose so these are the things
that are being presupposed
that the inner intention is different
from the one put
forward so you know that there's a
disjunction there and
conscience doesn't want there to be any
sort of disjunction we've had plenty of
that
in all the other shapes and forms and
dialectics of
moral life or ethical life that we've
been looking at so far
conscience wants to be the place where
we're beyond that
we don't have to ask that we know that
we're on the right track we know that
we're the
good person our inner intention
matches up with the intention put
forward opposites right two different
opposites
uh you know literally what you're what
you're aiming at
how often let's take a pause
before we go further into the hegel
thing how often
have we been convinced that we as
good people who know what the right
thing to do is
and are choosing to do the right thing
how often have we discovered within
ourselves
a little bit of a split a little bit of
a disjunction
between our public face
what we're saying about that and what we
really are inside
the inner intention
hegel goes on and he tells us that uh
this this intention put forward
is in fact uh the duty
right and the inner intention is what
the individual self
wills so what is duty the will
of the universal and pure consciousness
now
we've had this this disjunction running
throughout this entire section
and indeed throughout the phenomenology
this this splitting between
what i as an empirical existing
actual viewer click in in german
individual
want need demand
you know put forth intend
and what my better self
the more universal self the self that is
also
abstract the self that only truly
exists through the individual self what
that self
would want intend that's the good self
that has the duty
then we've got the whatever we want to
call it the empirical
the not so good self that that chooses
what it chooses
so in conscience this has been dealt
with
he says this distinction
now notice he doesn't say disjunction
or conflict this distinction
even being able to say these are
different from each other this is really
important
this distinction between the universal
consciousness
and the individual self is just what has
been
superseded alpha hobin in german right
we should remind ourselves very briefly
about what this means this is a key
term for hegel the dialectic proceeds by
auf haven by things being aufkahobin
which means that they're in some respect
they're left behind
but what's important of them has been
brought
in and in integrated at least to some
degree
so this this whole disjunction
has not just been annulled it's not just
been
left behind altogether it has been
superseded
and hegel says the supersession of this
is conscience
you know this this alpha of haben
is gavison so
he tells us that the self's immediate
knowing
that it is certain of itself is law and
duty
notice immediate right so the self
knowing that it is certain of itself is
law and duty now when you hear it framed
like that
you probably ought to say to yourself
whoa that is
that is one big claim now is hegel
making that claim hegel's saying that's
what conscience itself thinks about
itself
and that's what the you might call it
cultural representatives
at you know that given time in the
historical development and
what we can find of that also in the
present because
you know these dialectics replicate
themselves into our own present into our
own culture
that is what they tell themselves but
that's a big claim
right the very fact that you are certain
of its
of yourself and you know that to be the
case
is law and duty and we could say
duty for for what and here's that's a
great question because
any particular duty is not going to
be duty as as such in this case right
he goes on and he says its intention
through being its own intention is what
is right
all that's required is that it should
know this and should state its
conviction that it's knowing and willing
are right and so this is part of what
the super session
or auf haven of conscience consists in
knowing and saying the the german is
zagan right das
zaga and so what does it know it knows
that its intention
is right you can say well how does it
know that couldn't it be wrong well
we've left those doubts behind
that's why it's so dangerous right we're
not doubting that anymore we're not even
asking that question anymore we know our
intention is right
and then here's where we get to the most
interesting part of this paragraph for
me
i mentioned all these remarks about
language just a little bit earlier
it can't just know that it's right it
can't just act in that knowing it has to
externalize that
in language it has to say that it has to
assert that
and it's that means that it's got to say
it not just to itself but to somebody
else it's got to
make its point clear right and and
you've known people like this
people of conscience who they they
behave in a certain way
and sometimes you say oh yeah the person
of conscience their conscience was
properly formed
they really did the right thing great
example martin luther king not a perfect
individual but you know you read the
letter from a birmingham jail and you
look at his actions
you're like well he's driven by
conscience as well as principle and he's
doing the right thing and those who are
are criticizing him they're kind of off
base here and his conscience is what
allows him to do the thing
but the action although you know king
says that action by itself is commun
communicative and he's right about that
he also writes a letter
he also gives speeches he also engages
in saying right
and we know many other people who aren't
martin luther kings
who would love to think of themselves
that way or even who appropriate martin
luther king
and sort of take all the radical
elements out of his thought
and turn him into let's all be nice to
each other sort of sort of bs
kind of uh caricature in order so that
so that their conscience can be assuaged
and they can know that their intention
is right and then they also like blather
on endlessly about how great their
intention is
and we're like yeah you're a fraud we
see through your bs
but they don't see through their bs or
maybe there are little cracks through
which it shows
and those insecurities lead them to
assert all the more
these questions have no no significance
for my conscience
i have no doubts lots of doubtless
people at least with their public face
who are off base when it comes to
morality when it comes to political
organization when it comes to
how we ought to live together and what
we ought to value and prioritize
as human beings this is what is so
dangerous about conscience
right so it says that it's knowing and
willing our right
it declares this to itself and to
others he says the declaration of this
assurance in itself reads the form of
its particularity it thereby
acknowledges the necessary universality
of the self this is a universality that
it's asserting that it's trying to
you know latch on to but in many cases
as we're going to see it doesn't really
have
and so in calling itself conscience
gavison
it calls itself pure knowledge of itself
and pure abstract willing
so here's where we have the stuff i've
written about above here
it calls itself a universal knowing of
vissen
and willing volden right
which recognizes and acknowledges others
this is a very important thing to point
out
recognizes and acknowledges others
plural right
so recognizes and acknowledges a little
bit of a play on asm there
miller is translating honor honor kent
you know honor kennen as both
recognition
and acknowledgement perfectly fine this
is the thing that self-consciousness is
desiring and in this case
it is telling itself that it is giving
this to others it's also looking for it
from
others at the same time this is why
people can get so upset
when they say i'm acting on conscience i
will take my stand here
and you're like you're full of crap
buddy you're you're just self-serving
you know you're you're in the grips of
some ideology you're a partisan
you're you're not for some sort of
universal humanity
you're for your particular class your
particular group
your particular cronies your particular
race whatever it is
that that you know they are doing in in
you know and claiming that it's
universal conscience
they get very upset when you say that
why because they're not as secure as
as you would expect they're not getting
the recognition
or acknowledgement that they think they
are
thereby earning by giving it to others
so he goes on and he says
um it thinks it's the same as them for
they are
just as pure self-knowing and willing
and which for that reason is also
recognized and acknowledged by them
in the will of the self that is certain
of itself
in this knowledge that the self is
essential being
lies the essence of what is right now
again we should remind ourselves
this is what conscience this shape of
consciousness
is telling itself we should actually ask
is the knowledge the vision that it has
the knowing
really truly knowledge or is it
can pseudo knowledge so he says
therefore whoever says he acts in such
in such a way from conscience
speaks the truth for his conscience is
the self that knows and wills
right um speaks the truth the truth that
they're convinced of
at least not the truth in the absolute
sense
and he says it's essential that he
should say so
we come back again to the function of
language and expression why for the self
must be at the same time the universal
self
notice what he says next it is not
universal in the content of the act
insofar as it does
something and then you know that is is
communicative it displays the values
that the person has
that's still particular it has to talk
about itself
and its actions and its conviction in
such a way
that everybody else could hop on board
and say yeah yeah man
i'm just like this person over here
i'm like martin luther king or i'm like
martin luther his namesake right the one
i must stand here
or i'm like this person or this person
or this person
that's what language allows us to do we
move away from the content of the act
to the form of the act in that case
where he says that universality lies and
he says this form
is to be established as actual where can
it be established as actual
language he says it is the self which as
such
is actual where in language
which declares itself to be the truth
and just by doing so acknowledges all
other selves
and is acknowledged by them so
what we have here sounds really really
great right in language
is doing this universal action which is
conscience
leaving behind any doubts or qualms or
concerns
we know we're doing the right thing
that's one way to look at it another way
to look at it is
man there's a lot of different things
packed in here
and you're saying that they're all
basically unified
and integrated i don't know that that's
really the case
and language is one of the places
where these things can start separating
out from each other
and the doubts that we're having can
actually
come to light
conscience then in the majesty of its
elevation above specific law and every
content of duty
puts whatever content it pleases into
its knowing and willing
it is the moral genius which knows the
inner voice of what it immediately knows
to be a divine voice
and sense in knowing this it has an
equally immediate knowledge of existence
it is the divine creative power which in
its notion
possesses the spontaneity of life
equally it is in its own self-divine
worship
for its action as the contemplation of
its own divinity
paragraph 655 is another one of these
very short paragraphs where it turns out
that there's quite a bit going on
particularly if we read between the
lines
as we have to do with hegel's reference
to
moral genius right which is kind of an
interesting
term we'll talk about why in just a
moment but
let's let's look at the vocabulary and
the text that he's using here
it's really quite in some respects over
the top right and that that should be
signaling something to you but let's
look first at the text so he says
conscience then in the majesty of its
elevation
above specific law and every content of
duty
puts whatever content it pleases into
its knowing
and willing so there's a lot going on
there
what is it well we have conscience and
conscience is now at this point in the
majesty
this is you know where he's bringing in
some
royal language conscience in the majesty
of its elevation
above what specific law
particular things and content of duty
particular
duties so the person of conscience
remember
conscience isn't some sort of thing
floating out there
conscience is embodied in actual human
beings
who at this stage of consciousness
present themselves
as being in some respect better
than the people who came before them and
perhaps better than all the other people
who
are still at earlier stages or
dialectics of consciousness those who
are still earnest about actual duties
this person
can look at them and say oh it's so
sad that you still think that you have
to be bound by these
laws and and duties that are coming to
you from from without
this is me sort of legislating for all
humankind
it's sort of a dark side to kant's
kingdom of ends this person who subsumes
that
to themselves and then crowns themselves
king or queen
so conscience is going to
set aside any specific law
or content of duty not just because
it interferes with what conscience
decides it wants to do but
sort of in principle nobody can tell me
what to do
you know and we do see people like this
every once in a while who are like you
don't know me
and actually in some respects we can say
yeah of course i don't know you i don't
know every single thing about you
but i do know your type they're the type
of person to say that
i am somehow above everybody else and
what i think is right
i have decided i you know may not even
have any knowledge it may be a gut
feeling
and maybe whatever it is that i'm i'm
relying upon
and people like that often do quite
terrible things to those especially who
are
close to them or depending on them so
conscience
of course they may be good people too
they may be you know doing all sorts of
wonderful things
this is kind of a dangerous way to do it
though conscience he says
puts whatever content it pleases
into it's knowing and
willing and it's knowing and willing is
what in the previous paragraph
and the paragraphs before it we were
saying is this sort of
universality now it also ties in
not just willing and knowing but it's
going to also
lead to action handle
right the behavior and as we saw in the
previous paragraph it's also going to
lead to
speaking or expressing itself
communicating about its knowing and
willing it's got to blather to everybody
about what a great knowing and willing
it's got
how it's knowing and willing are the
best infallible
even so you know i think by this point
you may have recognized some some people
that you know
um if you don't know anybody like this
either you're living a blessed existence
or you might be that person
so so that's part of what's going on in
that very first
sentence now here's where we get to
something really interesting
hegel says it is the moral genius
which knows the inner voice of what it
immediately knows to be a divine voice
so let's let's pause for a moment on
this moral genius
more alicia genialite right
genius okay so in the
you know romantic period genius is
a really good term we still use it today
to describe
people that we think are really smart
and you know or
you know gifted in some other way we can
talk about a musical genius
and we can talk about somebody being a
genius of innovation
usually claims to genius are bs
you know you probe close enough you look
closely enough at that person
and it's not just you know coming out of
some
unexplica inexplicable or unknowable
void that happens to be within them
which turns out to be full of all sorts
of things that none of us could see
no i mean you actually look into the
lives of people that we consider to be
genius
and you can figure out a lot of how they
came up with their their conclusions
and oftentimes they'll actually tell you
in books that they write
and that's great right but the romantic
period did
and actually i mean this goes all the
way back to kant and then
comes through german idealism as well
you know when it comes to aesthetic
matters
they thought that genius was actually
you know a legitimate
category quite important and
you know hegel certainly talks about
that in his discussions of aesthetics
what about a moral genius well this is
where it gets interesting
and you know hegel is not a conscience
in there in the sense of like following
you know and locks up there's a lot of
kant in all this morality section and
and you know some other
previous sections but hegel you know is
trying to go beyond
kant as well um but kant is crystal
clear that anything that's
about the moral realm should be
universally explicable it's based on
concepts
it's based on notions that we can
compare with each other
it's not like the aesthetic where in
fact when it comes to beauty
kant says in in the third critique well
you know
it's different than the moral stuff you
know the good
makes kind of a universal demand on us
and we can explain it to others
what i find beautiful is not based on
concepts in that way
and i can certainly try to make an
argument why
you should see it as beautiful but you
might not and ultimately we
we may be very different from each other
and when it comes to like production
well the genius is going to be somebody
who knows how to
line things up properly and do the right
thing
right thing in that respect to produce
the beautiful or the sublime or produce
whatever it is that they're going to
produce right
does it work that way with morality no
one sign that you've got morality wrong
is that you think it's unique to you or
only
people like you can actually get it if
that's the case you're actually probably
immoral from the perspective
of that a moral genius
is kind of a weird bird right because to
say that somebody has genius elevates
them above all the rest of us
and says we can't really understand
what's going on with them but they can
tell us what's good what we ought to do
now this goes back to my own army days i
remember when i was in basic training
we had this guy he was one of the drill
sergeant sergeant huff
and he would use the word hero
in a very sarcastic and derogatory way
and you could tell by the tone of his
voice
when he was talking to recruits he would
say hey hero
you know he had kind of a weird twang
that i can't capture
and the contempt was just dripping
through that
you're not a hero you're actually some
schmuck
who's you know under me and is not even
remotely close to a good soldier at this
time right but he was calling you a hero
to drive
home to you the fact that you're not a
hero you're not anything
imagine something like that tone here in
hegel's voice
as you're reading this when he talks
about moral genius
because i think that's what puts it into
proper perspective and it just gets
thicker as we go on right
so the moral genius knows the inner
voice of what it immediately knows to be
a divine voice
fortunately for itself it's it's voice
right it's voice as divine
since in knowing this it has an equally
immediate knowledge of existence
it is the divine creative power which in
its notion possesses the spontaneity
of life whatever it decides to put into
willing knowing acting and speaking
that is the voice of genius that is the
voice of god
and everyone else should you know listen
to it and this person is so fortunate to
be a channel
of the divinity and he says equally it
is
in its own self divine worship for its
action
is the contemplation of its own divinity
when it acts it looks at its action it's
like
and and the lord said that it was good
or
you know whatever we want to frame it as
right it registers its own action is so
wonderful hegel is not putting this
forth because he believes in
any of this he's putting this forth as
this is where conscience
is going to go as a shape of
consciousness and when we read this we
should be like oh
this is a burn and things are going to
go
topsy-turvy real quick
you